here's the short history of me born in
1961 went to high school never I went to
one University for a semester American
University in Washington DC didn't like
it knew I couldn't afford 4 years of
student loan didn't want to hang out
with people who were enraptured by
Stroh's beer and marijuana this wasn't
gonna be for me so I hit the streets and
pursued the minimum wage jobs that I'd
had all through high school and that was
for me that was me in the late 70s the
last straight job I had was 1981 head
manager of a haagen-dazs in Georgetown
in Washington DC on Wisconsin Avenue at
the intersection of Wisconsin and o'the
street making 375 an hour $4 an hour or
something like that working 40 to 60
hours a week I had a small apartment
which I shared with an old pal of mine
I had a small record collection an
ailing VW automobile and a little tiny
life with my minimum wage job which I
where I liked and I looked at my life
and realized this is probably about as
good as it's gonna get for me I might
quit this place and go work at my
friends record store cuz I like to being
around records that I could probably run
his store very well knowing what I knew
about retail at that point and then I
got a very lucky break because at that
same time I was very frustrated I said
well this is gonna be a very tough life
it's gonna be a life of a lot of
standing on my feet a lot of work taking
it from other people and having very
little to show for it by Friday you know
Friday evening and then Black Flag the
famous band whose friends of mine they
played in New York I was in Washington I
took a ride up to go see him because
they weren't coming down to my town
I jumped on stage and sang with him that
night a song because I had to go back
down in DC and go work like some awful
shift they called me a few days later at
the ice cream store and said you know
we're looking for a singer because the
rhythm guitar player wants to I'm sorry
the vocalist wants to move down to
rhythm guitar tell I've told the story
before and we're holding auditions you
want to crack at this because we saw you
on stage the other night you're pretty
wild I looked at the ice cream scoop in
my
and my chocolate bespattered apron and
my future in the world of minimum wage
work or I could go up to New York and
audition for this crazy band who was my
favorite what's the worst is gonna
happen to me I miss a day of work ooh
there goes 21 bucks and I get humiliated
in front of my favorite band
yeah humiliation and young people kind
of go together I was used to it and so I
I took a train up there I walked into
this practice place in the East Village
I'm standing there with the band with a
microphone in my hand they said pick the
tune and I sang every song they had you
know improvising most of it two times
through we did the set they said okay
you have a seat we're gonna go have a
band meeting whatever that means and
they came back like 10 minutes later
said okay you're in I said what do you
mean they said you're the singer in
Black Flag I said so what do I do they
go he'll quit your job you pack your
gear you meet us on the road here's the
here's the tour itinerary here's the
lyrics we'll see you soon
so fairly numb I went back down to
Washington with this passel of lyrics in
my hand went to my boss and said I'm not
exactly quitting but here's this thing
that happened and he said it's your shot
I said yeah he said take it and that was
late July 1981 about 30-some years ago
and that's what happened to me I won the
lottery and I was in this band Black
Flag for years made a lot of records
played a lot of shows learned a lot
started writing sort of publishing
company in that time and in the 80s
Hollywood directors started coming to me
like you're crazy you can you act I'm
like yeah I'm starving can you pay I
mean I'm looking for work and never
forgetting what I have to go back to $8
you know Hagen does so I said yes to
every acting job yes to every audition
worked on my little publishing company
started doing poetry readings and
speaking dates in the 90s want to do a
voiceover yeah and so I said yes to
everything worked like a crazy man
realizing guys like me fais
the times I was around a lot of great
bands and rarely did they get over the
wall people much more talented than
Oliver B I don't have talent I have
tenacity
you know I've discipline I have focus
and I know without any illusion where I
come from and what I can go back to and
that's why I said a while ago in the 80s
I saw what was happening with money I
was watching it shift very quickly I was
watching the middle class go away and I
was a 23 year old maniac but I got it
and that's when I realized you better
get playing BCDE F and G otherwise
you're gonna starve to death in the
America the America is not a place you
live in it's a video game that you that
you survive you know I'm not only an
American I'm an American esteem Erica in
spite of what it wants to do to people
like me and so through saying yes to
everything realizing people like me have
to write it three times and other people
have to write it once that I have to
show up early I'll probably get lost on
the way to the location and that I
should probably watch shut up and learn
rather than shoot my mouth off I am
where I am right now which is a vastly
different position than I was thirty
years ago 20 years ago in ten years ago
so it is basically a story of a lot of
luck but taking advantage of opportunity
working really damn hard knowing there
was no choice for me but to work really
hard and that's it and that's not a
unique story what was unique as I got to
be in my favorite band like they came to
me and said hey we're auditioning people
I was like because had they not plucked
me out of Washington DC a great town
what would have happened to me I
probably would have gone to work for my
friend's record store which would have
eventually folded which it went away and
then what I would have done I don't know
maybe gotten some female pregnant and
then a young dad I don't know you know
the America would have happened to me
and so I got a lucky break but at least
I did something with it the repeating
factors of my life have been
application discipline focus repetition
you know a gig a gig again what are you
doing tomorrow 8 o'clock on stage we're
doing the night after I'll be on stage
we're about 2 months from now I'll be
still on that same tour because I manage
myself I know where I'm going I might
finish it
I might not survive it but I'm the one
booking it
you